.
MAYBE ILLEGAL CROSSINGS WOULD
COME TO A HALT.
MAYBE WE COULD STATION IN THERE
AND IT WOULD ALL STOP.
JOINING IS NOW THE FULL REPORT
IS SOMEONE WHO'S ACTUALLY
VISITED THE BORDER MANY TIMES,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARA CARTER
JOINS US LIVE IN BROWNSVILLE,
TEXAS.
SARAH, THANKS FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M HERE IN BROWNSVILLE, BEHIND
ME IS THE PORT OF ENTRY, IT
BUTTRESSES MEXICO.
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU, RIGHT
ACROSS THE BORDER, SEVERAL MILES
FROM US IS OPEN PARK OR OVER
8,000, OVER 8,000 JUST HERE,
PEOPLE ARE WAITING TO COME
ACROSS THE BORDER.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
TOLD BY THE SMUGGLERS THAT
TITLE 42 IS GOING TO END ON
WEDNESDAY.
RIGHT NOW CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS
DID HAVE A STATE TO UPHOLD
TITLE 42.
THEY ARE TO UPHOLD IT UNTIL
TOMORROW AT 5:00 P.M. WHEN
THEY'RE GOING TO GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO RESPOND AS TO WHY WE
DON'T NEED TITLE 42.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS.
FEDERAL ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
ARE CONCERNED.
THEY ARE SEEING MIGRANT SWELLS
COMING AND NOT JUST IN
BROWNSVILLE, IN McALLEN,
TEXAS, CROSS THE BORDER IN
ARIZONA AND CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
THEY SAY WITH THE REMOVAL OF
TITLE 42 THEY EXPECT UP TO
18,000 PEOPLE A DAY.
THAT'S ONLY BECAUSE OF THE
REMOVAL OF TITLE 42.
THEY ARE EXPECTING THOSE SWELLS
TO COME IN.
I SPOKE TO VICE PRESIDENT THE
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL COUNCIL
HERE IN THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY,
CHRIS CABRERA.
HE SAID THOSE PEOPLE COMING IN
RIGHT NOW AREN'T JUST PEOPLE
BEING HELD BACK FROM TITLE 42.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
BEING HELD BACK.
PEOPLE FROM VENEZUELA, CUBA,
AFGHANISTAN, PAKISTAN.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LISTEN TO
WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> BASED ON WHAT YOU SEEN THE
LAST FEW YEARS, HOW MUCH OF A
DIFFERENCE IS IT GOING TO BE TO
REMOVE TITLE 42?
IF WE ARE ALREADY SEEING THESE
NUMBERS, IS IT JUST GOING TO BE
MORE OF THE SAME OR FAR WORSE?
>> IT'S GOING TO BE FAR WORSE.
WE HAVE CERTAIN PEOPLE WE CAN
SEND BACK UNDER TITLE 42 BUT
THERE ARE CERTAIN COUNTRIES THAT
CAN'T BE SENT BACK UNDER
TITLE 42, AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING NOW MOSTLY GRAY
VENEZUELANS, NICARAGUANS,
CUBANS.
THEY ARE COMING ACROSS IN HUGE
NUMBERS OTHERS NOTHING WE CAN DO
ABOUT IT.
IT'S FOR EVERYONE ELSE.
ANYONE ELSE IS NOT GOING TO BE
AFFECTED.
SPEAK OF 15,000 IN MEXICO
WAITING TO CROSS, THAT'S IT?
>> ON TOP OF THAT YOU HAVE THE
OTHERS GETTING THE MEMO THAT ARE
GOING MOBILIZE AND COME OVER
FROM ALL OVER, NOT JUST CENTRAL
AND SOUTH AMERICA.
WE HAVE A LOT FROM EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES, ASIAN COUNTRIES.
YOU NAME IT.
THEY ARE COMING ALREADY.
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
COME.
>> DESPITE THE FACT JUDGES HAVE
UPHELD REMAIN IN MEXICO AND
TITLE 42, BORDER PATROL AGENCY
OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DOESN'T UPHOLD THE LAW, THEN THE
LAW WILL NOT BE UPHELD.
IT WON'T EVEN MATTER.
PEOPLE WILL JUST KEEP POURING
IN.
PETE.
>> Pete: SARA, HOLD ON.
THE WORLD IS COMING.
IS THAT JUST MEANS WE'RE GOING
TO PROCESS THEM FASTER AND
RELEASE THEM, MORE PEOPLE IN
MASS?
THE PROCESS DOESN'T CHANGE.
IT'S JUST A BIGGER MASS RELEASE
OF PEOPLE?
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
WE ARE SEEING A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE.
THEY TALK ABOUT APPREHENSIONS OF
THE BORDER.
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
APPREHENSIONS ARE RELEASED
WITHIN A DAY OR TWO.
WE DON'T HAVE THE FACILITIES
HERE IN TEXAS, ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNOR, TEXAS DPS, BORDER
PATROL, IMMIGRATIONS AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT TO HOLD ALL THE
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS CORRECT,
THEY ARE BRINGING THEM IN.
THEY ARE PROCESSING THEM, THEY
CAN EVEN DO FULL BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
THEY ARE JUST BEING RELEASED
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
BEFORE I GOT ON WITH YOU, YOUNG
FAMILY WALKED BY ME THEY HAD A
BABY AND YOU CAN SEE THEY JUST
COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
THEY WERE ASKING FOR DIRECTIONS
TO THE BUS STATION.
THEY HAD A CHILD WITH THEM.
PEOPLE ARE SLEEPING IN THE
STREETS HERE IN TEXAS.
THEY DON'T STAY IN TEXAS.
THEY END UP ALL ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
WORST OF ALL BEFORE I LET YOU
GO, THE FACT THAT MANY TIMES THE
CARTELS ARE MOVING A LOT OF
PEOPLE, BIG, LARGE GROUPS AND
WHILE THEY ARE DOING THAT, THEY
ARE MOVING FENTANYL AND OTHER
NARCOTICS INTO THE UNITED STATES
AND THERE'S NOBODY THERE TO STOP
THEM.
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS CRISIS
OF OUR NATION.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO'S COMING IN.
IT'S AFFECTING EVERYONE, NOT
JUST THE PEOPLE CROSSING THE
BORDER BUT OUR CHILDREN AND THE
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES AS
WELL.
>> Pete: WE SPENT ALL THOSE
MAN-HOURS PROCESSING HORDES OF
PEOPLE, THEIR AGENTS THAT ARE
NOT WORKING THE LINE IS PEOP